hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy and I'm very excited to let you
all know about the work that Khan
Academy is now doing in artificial
intelligence obviously over the last
many months there's been a lot of talk
about artificial intelligence that has
been both exciting and scary we all see
the potential that it could have to help
people to maybe even one day tutor
people but we also know that there are
some drawbacks it can hallucinate
sometimes make up facts it doesn't
always get the math correct maybe it can
introduce bias or maybe
students might try to do things with it
that aren't fully appropriate or try to
get it to do their assignments for them
and so us we at Khan Academy we view it
as our responsibility as a
not-for-profit with a mission of free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere that also Prides itself on
being at The Cutting Edge of technology
and how technology can be used to
accelerate learning review do it as our
responsibility to start deeply working
with artificial intelligence but
threading the needles so that we can
maximize the benefits and mitigate the
risks today Khan Academy is launching
conmigo and we're putting it behind con
Labs which is a new program we're doing
as part of Khan Academy where we can
take new technology that we think has a
lot of promise and we can give access
initially to a smaller subset of
educators of parents of students and
donors so that they can begin to test it
and as we refine it we can bring it out
to more and more people con mego is the
artificial intelligent assistant that is
integrated into everything that Khan
Academy does that a student can do that
a parent can do that a teacher can do
for example if you're doing an exercise
on Khan Academy you want to hint you
essentially want a tutor we think
artificial intelligence needs to be a
tool for real learning and not for
cheating and that means that it's great
to have conmigo be a tutor
[Music]
foreign
use case is especially powerful as we
come out of the pandemic all of us as
Educators want to address unfinished
learning but we know that tutoring can
only work if it's connected to what
students are already doing in the
classroom and ideally actually being
able to do it in the classroom and this
is exactly what we're doing as part of
conmigo and what's really exciting about
these next Generation models that we're
working with is that they can do math
they don't always do it perfectly but it
is improving dramatically and quickly
week by week so we thought this is the
time to try it out artificial
intelligence and large language models
introduce the possibility of doing
completely new activities that weren't
possible before for example teachers
spend a lot of time writing lesson plans
what if they had an artificial
intelligent teaching assistant that can
help them write their lesson plan
thank you
[Music]
on the student side instead of just
doing things for the student what if it
could act as a coach to do things with
the student write something alongside
the student making sure that the student
is doing the bulk of the work but
pulling it out of them making it more
fun making it more engaging
[Music]
foreign
a world which we actually are putting as
part of our Labs activities where
students can debate any topic they like
within reasonable topics where the AI
can take the other side and they can
really fine-tune their arguments they
can have conversations with historical
figures or figures from literature they
can get help on problems that they might
have to do in class or in homework but
once again not in a way that it just
gives them the answer but in a way that
a good tutor would do it that it helps
nudge the students for them to figure it
out themselves
[Music]
and the other thing we're doing is we're
adding even more safeguards safeguards
within the activities themselves but
also ways for parents and teachers to
monitor Student Activity they can see
log of all of what the students have
been up to and also to get notifications
if there are any conversations that seem
to be on the edge or inappropriate so to
be clear this is just the beginning and
we aren't launching these features to
every Khan Academy user right now
instead we are prioritizing teachers and
schools and districts that are already
part of our Khan Academy District
offering we're also going to allow those
of you who can help support these
efforts as a donor the efforts to build
out do all the r d that will also be a
way to get priority on the waiting list
to be an early tester of conmigo I think
together all of us teachers parents
policy makers District leaders if we
work together hand in hand we can find
ways to maximizing the benefits of this
powerful technology while mitigating the
risks and if we do that we can literally
empower the lives of billions and it
will be a very exciting next couple of
years thank you
foreign